(suspenseful music)
- On March 25th, 2015, the world learned
that Zayn Malik left
the band One Direction,
and from our perspective at
BuzzFeed, the Internet exploded
with the grief of teenagers everywhere.
We hit the streets of Hollywood
to find out how people reacted.
Zayn Malik left the band One Direction.
- (gasps) Oh, I heard that!
(guys laugh)
That was real?
- Oh, dear.
- You know, I feel like we
all knew something like this
is going to happen at some point.
- A plus!
(girls laugh)
Good job!
- I don't mind, because
he looks pretty bored
on stage all the time anyway, so.
- I don't know. I kind of understand
how the artist, they grow apart.
- He left in One Direction? Was it down?
- Uhm, well --
What was his name again?
- No. (laughs)
- No.
- Nope.
- It happens.
- It doesn't hurt the group.
- I'm sure he made a
lot of money from One --
One Direction?
Well, being a normal 22 year old, I'm 22,
I don't really know what that even means.
(rock music)
- Zayn needs to think about Zayn.